hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast diet and gene
interactions in the control of central
cell metabolism presented by Sophie Pro
select PhD student quadrant Institute
bioscience University of East Anglia I'm
Alexis Krause of lab rats and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab herbs and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on our sponsor please visit thermo
Fisher comm now let's get started before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I'd like
to now introduce our presenter Sophie
Pro select Sophie is a BB RSC funded PhD
student studying the role of dietary
compounds and the genetic control
estelle metabolism at the quadruped
Institute UK aside from her research
duties sophie is a keen science
communicator as City coordinator for the
pint of science outreach festival and
chair founder of the UEA science
communication society Sophie manages
various public engagement initiative
vert eise's through local TV radio and
print media streams by combining her
scientific expertise with the fierce
passion for adult education and lifelong
learning
Sophie hopes to integrate her research
career with media production for mass
education post PhD Sophie you may now
begin your presentation
hello thank you for the introduction
welcome to my webinar entitled diet and
gene interactions in the control of
central cell metabolism I'm super sonic
based at the quorum Institute in Norwich
and today's webinar I'm going to first
give you an introduction into our
research group here what we do and our
expertise I'm going to talk about
bioactive compounds from broccoli what
those bioactive compounds are and more
importantly how we map how we analyze
the metabolic effects of those broccoli
bioactives I'm also going to talk a
little bit about gene called purple and
it's implication with diet and health
I'm going to first introduce what purple
is and how we explore its role in cancer
metabolism then I'm going to end with
the question could with your cancer with
broccoli and that's not quite as crazy
as it sounds so I've promised a little
bit about me
I'm a third year PhD student based at
the quarterman t2 in Norwich in the UK I
started my PhD in 2015 and my current
project surprise-surprise
focuses on the role of broccoli
bioactives
and RNA turnover in metabolic control so
I studied from my BSC in biomedicine
here in Norwich at the University of
East Anglia and decide decided to stay
here and from my PhD in my spare time
I'm a passionate science communicator a
city coordinator for the point of
science outreach festival basically I
get scientists to come into the pub and
speak to the general public about their
research I've been doing that since 2017
and I'm also an activist for the
protection and inclusion of neuro
diversity in research so follow me on
Twitter if you want to find out about
any of that I'm quite an active tweeter
and I love to hear from you and your
thoughts on my webinar and just general
chitchat really and so also a little bit
about our group
and we're a mixed group of human
biologists clinicians plant biologists
and we're supported by a fantastic
bioinformatician and two analytical
chemists we're very lucky here in
Norwich that we have a very broad range
of expertise across the Norwich research
park we work with clinicians from the
Norfolk and Norwich University Hospital
and plant biologists from the John Innes
Centre which we luckily based just
across the road from and this sort of
perfect storm of expertise has made our
group particularly unique when it comes
to studying bioactive compounds in foods
particularly crops and the sort of
clinical effects and outcomes of cancer
research so we investigate the role of
broccoli bioactives in cell metabolism
and cancer interception so we use novel
novel broccoli cell lines developed by
our group as I mentioned we work very
closely with the John Innes Center who
are world famous for crop science and we
we use as I say these novel broccoli
cell lines developed by Richard Mizen
who conventionally bred these broccoli
lines which are high in levels of
glucosinolates
particularly glucoraphanin and he bred
these broccoli lines by conventional
breeding techniques using ancestral
broccoli lines and and modern crops to
enhance these levels of glucosinolates
which we use in human intervention
studies like I say these broccoli crops
were bred to contain high levels of
certain bioactive metabolites and we
basically turn them into soup broccoli
and Stilton soup which are great for
human intervention studies so one thing
that's really unique about our group is
that we use these are human intervention
studies to inform in-vitro cell culture
work usually when you think of
translational biomedicine or
translational research you think of a
bench-to-bedside approach well we employ
a bed
like the bench approach so we can keep
relevant and and we find this is a
really useful approach to cancer
research using human intervention data
to inform basic science research and to
diet and health it keeps us relevant and
it means that this sort of
cross-disciplinary
expertise can be sort of maximized to
get the most we can out of our research
so this one isn't a hard sell a broccoli
diet is associated with a reduced risk
of cancer we all know broccoli is good
for us because it's green broccoli is
rich in fiber vitamins minerals but it
also contains health-promoting bioactive
compounds so compounds are biologically
active a diet rich in broccoli is
reduced is associated with a reduced
risk of multiple cancers including
prostate breast long if there's a type
of cancer for that sort of tissue
there's probably a study looking at
broccoli bioactives and that kind of
cancer this is quite widely studied and
but anti-cancer properties of broccoli
have largely been attributed to one
class of compounds in particular called
glucosinolates in particular
glucoraphanin and its metabolites or for
a fame so broccoli and other Brassica
vegetables might I add and contain high
levels of glucosinolates but broccoli
contains perhaps the most so we ingest
these glucosinolates or glucoraphanin
and to name one when we eat broccoli and
upon mastication of the broccoli and the
plant material and the vacuoles of the
plant are broken and enzymes which can
convert you graphing in to its
metabolites sulforaphane released and so
there's some conversion of glucose into
sulforaphane in the mouth but also by
our gut microbiota and a lot of greg
raffinate is converted by the gut
microbiota into sulforaphane which can
be absorbed in the lower gut
so for refined
and to systemic circulation and can have
all kinds of bioactive effects
throughout the body
so sulforaphane is a potent activator as
the nrf2 antioxidant response so I could
give an entire webinar to be honest on
nrf2 and the antioxidant response but
that's kind of going into too much
detail there is beyond the scope of this
particular webinar but basically what's
offering does is it conjugates to
glutathione glutathione would usually
mop up reactive oxygen species so the
The Binding of so for referring to
glutathione changes the redox status of
the cell and initially is a pro-oxidant
but this a tune of the antioxidant
response the nrf2 antioxidant response
to be specific and what regulates the
expression of detoxifying genes in the
cell so overall so for assigning though
acting initially as a pro-oxidant is an
antioxidant and this antioxidant effect
that we think it enough to push cancer
over the edge and sulforaphane has been
shown as a promising novel therapy for
cancer interception we do run our own
human intervention studies that are I'll
just mentioned that in a second and but
there's a particularly interesting
interesting paper by hotel that was
published earlier this year and
detailing the use of a broccoli diet in
a targeted targeted treatment of
colorectal cancer and mice I really
recommend if you're interested in diet
and cancer cancer interception go and
give it a read because it's a really
exciting paper so I promised I'd
mentioned one of our human intervention
studies and that was the escape study so
escape and stands for somehow exploring
broccoli diet and prostate cancer
interception I can't give you too many
details on this because it's currently
in review but all I can say
look out for it it's going to be
exciting so men with prostate cancer
recruited to this intervention study
where they were asked to consume one
portion of 400 grams of broccoli and
Stilton soup per week so we looked at
standard broccoli and then the high
glucoraphanin broccoli that was
developed by our group and we had a look
at and in the prostate biopsy in blood
and urine and gene expression and
metabolite concentration and also cancer
grade or whole grade and so you can find
more details of this trial on clinical
trials gov and the link is in the corner
and below and like I say this one's
going to be an exciting one when it
comes out to keep an eye out for that so
as I mentioned broccoli contains high
levels of these glucosinolate
particularly glue carafe and in which we
know if by active against cancer but
broccoli also contains other proactive
compounds and in addition to glue carafe
Ihnen broccoli contains other sulfur
metabolites which are particularly
abundant in in Brassica crops or
broccoli crops and they're the compounds
that if you've ever if you've been
cooking broccoli they give it the
distinct broccoli smell the sulfurous
smell that you get from cooking Brassica
cooking cabbage cooking broccoli and
these these sort of containing
metabolites can be found in the prostate
biopsies of men consuming the broccoli
intervention diet such as those on the
escapes day that I mentioned and these
are the broccoli metabolites one of
which I have an example on the
right-hand side here and can be broken
down by the microbiota just like
glucoraphanin
so for feign this example here at msl
l-cysteine source oxide can be broken
down to daughter compounds and then psi
and mm TSO which literature details at
high levels can be used
as a bioactive to inform protein studies
literature also report antimutagenic and
Andy diabetic effective of these various
broccoli sulphur metabolites in addition
to sulforaphane and but most of the
studies on broccoli bioactives use Supra
physiological concentrations much higher
concentrations than you would get from a
standard broccoli diet and certainly
higher concentrations than you'd get
from that 400 grams per week
concentration dosage that we give to the
intervention the intervention and
volunteers so it's baking they use quite
a reductionist model really looking at
perhaps or for Efrain only which like I
say is widely studied and looking at
these super physiological concentrations
you have to kind of consider how
relevant some of the current literature
is if we're talking about diet and
cancer interception so it's really
important for us to define our cell
models and to keep relevant to whatever
we're studying we have to choose
carefully and in our case we chose P
nt1-a immortalized human prostate
epithelial cell lines and tachi to
mortalized and human hepatocellular
carcinoma cell line and really the value
of of using two cells two cell lines is
so that you can assess those mechanisms
which are conserved amongst different
tissues and those mechanisms which are
divergent from tissue to tissue so
you're able to compare and contrast and
as well an important decision for us in
looking at a liver cells whilst we were
researching prostate cancer using a
liver model helps us and think about
systemic metabolism or it helps think
about and we can use varying glucose
concentrations to mimic hyper or hypo
glycemic diabetic states and this allows
us to test metabolic pathway
in a way which we wouldn't probably do
using just a prostate cell model we also
have normal human hepatocytes th le two
cells which are immortalized so line or
mouth primary hepatocyte available and
we do dip in and out of using these
models where we need a little bit of
confirmation or backup to something that
we may have already seen another cell
line and so as I say
using multiple cell lines means that
you're able to comparing a trust across
tissues and across cell types but these
two cell lines that we've chosen hep g2
and P nt1-a are both highly glycolytic
so we can assess those mechanisms which
are conserved but but also also those
which are divergent and and by
challenging these cells in different
glucose environments we're able to
simulate a diet or metabolic syndrome
scenario so next we need to define our
treatments because we must answer a
relevant biological question we need to
think about the toxicity of these
broccoli bioactives that we're treating
ourselves with some of these bio actives
cause toxicity in in vitro when used
really high concentrations and that
certainly is not physiologically
relevant so when we need to investigate
that before any sort of cell studies so
when we culture cells and we measure
metabolic activity with a colorimetric
change in wst one reagent like this
example that I have on the right here so
we treat with increasing concentrations
or an increasing dosage of our compound
of interest and then look at
colorimetric change in WS to be one
reagent which is indicative of metabolic
activity and a decrease in in viability
to reduce decrease in metabolic activity
indicate as I have an example here in
viability now this is a bit of a you
have to take this with a bit of a pinch
of salt because we are looking at
metabolically active
and compounds here and but certainly
when you have a metabolic activity which
is degrees - sort of 10% of the original
capacity and this can be considered
indicative of cell death this is also
really revealing in terms of which
compounds we choose to study because the
plant metabolites themselves are not
always directly responsible for their
associated biological effect as I
mentioned earlier glucoraphanin is
converted to sulforaphane s MCSO is
converted to mm TSO and mm TSI and it's
not always a parent compound which is
bioactive and sometimes it's the
daughter compound and we've shown that
that these daughter metabolites are
toxic beyond 125 micro molar
concentrations in in vitro and whereas
the the parent compound shows no toxic
effect at all and to show no toxic
effect really suggests no biological
activity at these sort of super
physiological and concentrations so
we've defined our cell model we've
defined our cell treatment so next the
question is do sulphur metabolites
from broccoli do these broccoli biopsies
ultimate ABA's them and well they do
because because I'm speaking to you here
now so we we can use a variety of
techniques but our first port of call is
really to look at a generalist approach
to analyzing metabolism in these cell
lines and so we culture cells in micro
plates and treat with a physiological
concentration of our compound which is
informed by our human intervention
studies prostate biopsies and blood and
urine samples we can estimate and
physiological concentrations of these
compounds treat our cells in vitro and
then we use a machine called the
seahorse extracellular flux analyzer to
measure metabolic rate in live cells so
I love this machine I think it's
fantastic it's really great getting it
and overall snapshot of energy
metabolism in life cells and through the
injection of drug compounds oolagah
myosin sccp rotenone and myosin and we
can really test metabolic capacity so
you call to your cells in these micro
plates inject drug compounds over the
course of the assay and using a
fluorescent probe you measure
extracellular acidification which is
indirect measurement of catalysis and
oxygen consumption rate which is
indirect measurement of mitochondrial
respiration again this is another thing
that could have an entire webinar on
itself but information about this this
sort of assay can be found and
manufacturer's website and it's really
great I think for offering an overall
snapshot of live cell metabolism so what
does the seahorse as I look like it
looks like this so subtle metabolism
metabolites were shown to increase
glycolytic rate as you can see by a car
on the left hand side and maximum
mitochondrial capacity on the right hand
side in PMT 180 cells so compound
treated cells in red show an increase
glycolytic rate and it increased maximum
mitochondrial capacity compared to
control treated cells which is denoted
in blue so from there we've had an
overall snapshot of metabolism and
through this live cell energy phenotype
I did I didn't mention there that these
measurements are taken in live cells of
metabolism as it's happening which is
really cool you can see this real-time
change but then once we've seen that we
want to have a look more specifically at
what's going on with specific enzymes
and prove metabolism a little bit more
in a bit more of a detailed kind of way
so from there we go to RNA level
analysis and again with cultured cells
and treat them with our compound of
interest extract RNA and then we can
choose to do qrt-pcr for target gene
expression or whole genome RNA
sequencing we do both
I have just sent some samples off to Mac
Rajan for sequencing but also the
individual gene expression and looking
at these differential gene expressions
helps us identify pathways and networks
which are affected by our compound
treatment so I did some qrt-pcr for
glycolytic enzymes again in prostate
epithelial immortalized cell line P
nt1-a cells treated with compound and we
saw a dose-dependent increase in these
flora lytic enzymes so it appears from
our seahorse assay and from our targeted
gene expression analysis that our
compound of interest our sulphur
metabolite is increasing glycolysis in
PN t1a cells so by increasing glycolysis
in these cells and could this compound
support cancer interception will to
answer that we need to understand a
little bit about the pathogenesis of
prostate cancer so cancer is a largely
metabolic disease and cancer cells
exhibit the guar bug effect so unhealthy
metabolism glucose is converted by
roommate and then that's shunted into
the TCA cycle and oxidative
phosphorylation to generate lots of ATP
this is normal under conditions with
oxygen but the Warworld effect basically
means that in those same oxygenated
conditions cell of preferentially
metabolizing in an anaerobic kind of way
cells prefer preferentially respire with
non mitochondrial respiration even in
the presence of oxygen and mitochondrial
metabolism is perturbed in the wild load
effect those cells become sort of
addicted to glycolytic substrates like
glucose or glutamine and these high
rates of glycolysis are thought to
generate metabolites needed for anabolic
processes and notably cell growth in
cancer and that interestingly prostate
cancer does not exhibit the Warburg
effect and prostate epithelial tissue
and
does utilize glue glue does utilize
glycolysis to generate citrate an
important constituent of seminal fluid
and this is a normal function normal
healthy function prostate epithelial
tissue so by increasing glycolysis are
we in fact increasing the normal healthy
functions of this prostate epithelial
tissue and contributing to cancer
interception is that possible so we also
have to think about systemic metabolic
health as well as cellular metabolic
health in cancer prevention because
obesity and poor metabolic health is
also a risk factor for cancer
pathogenesis and surprise surprise
broccoli diet is associated with
improved metabolic health this is
another one of our studies our human
intervention studies where we use again
high glucose in broccoli and this
delivers increased levels of dietary so
for a vein and we saw that volunteers on
this diet were showing improved markers
of metabolic health but they showed also
a clustered metabolic response
correlated with polymorphisms in this
gene known as PAP org so could purpled
influence the cellular and systemic
metabolism and be causing these custom
metabolic responses that we saw in our
intervention study well we need to know
first what purple is and that's been a
challenge PAP longer the poly a
polymerase poly a polymerase gamma to be
specific and it's it largely under study
to be honest it catalyzes the sequential
addition of adenine residues to RNA
transcript so it's denoted here on the
right hand side as par poly a polymerase
and it formed part of this cleavage and
polyadenylation complex which is
responsible for post translational
modifications of RNA transcripts so it
can first ability or signals transcript
for degradation depending on the poly a
tail length or poly a pattern
and this potentially affects a range of
pathways within the cell and one thing
that's interesting about a book is that
it's over expressed in many cancers and
many cancers and as we've demonstrated
from our human but human intervention
study snips within this gene and appear
to be correlated with metabolic health
so what's the metabolic role of papal to
investigate this we use hep T 2 and P
and T 1 a cells again transfected with
Si RNA small interfering RNA so these
are small RNA RNA nucleotides of about
20-25 nucleotides in length and they
complimentary base pair to your gene
interest and signal it for degradation
so the overall effect of using NFI RNA
is it the gene of interest and is
abrogated the expression is abrogated
it's not knocked down completely but
it's significantly reduced and you can
then run comparative assays on your cell
population to antagonize what the effect
of this gene might be so we did exactly
that we coated cells and prepared lysate
of quarters treated with SI RNA and then
we looked at targeted analysis of
metabolite levels using lcms as I said
we're supported here by some very
talented chemists who helped very much
with with protocol development and the
lc-ms side of things but then is also
the option of high-throughput
metabolomics and we have we have sent
off samples and timet a blonde in the
past so we measured multiple metabolic
intermediates in a sample of either
cells or or media by lcms and we can
show the
when normalized to cell number there's a
decrease in metabolite concentrations
following gene knockdown this was
representative of various metabolites
across TCA cycle and so this helps us
identify where might be enzymatic
bottlenecks in in the pathway and as I
mentioned earlier so for a frame for
example affect the redox status of a
cell so these are often redox sensitive
enzymes
so to summarize we've demonstrated that
more that there are multiple bio actives
that can be derived from a broccoli diet
and that glucoraphanin as an example
it's already well studied but there are
other sort of containing metabolites
that perhaps warrant further study we've
reported on the backs bio activity of
certain sulfur containing comfortable
lights and identifying that it's often
the daughter compound not the parent
compound that is responsible for the
biological effects and that these
metabolites fundamentally alter energy
metabolism in vitro of both normal and
cancer cell lines we've demonstrated and
this broccoli diet may interact with
genotype notably the genotype org to
cause inter individual variation in the
response to a broccoli diet and of
course we've identified a normal
metabolic role for an RNA polymerase
that had not previously been associated
with metabolic control so this really
tells us that we need a
multi-dimensional approach to cell based
research broccoli contains multiple
potent bio actives which have a which
could have a synergistic effect in in
vivo and many in vitro studies have not
taken this into account they've taken a
reductionist approach focusing on one
bioactive only but our research
demonstrates the pitfalls of that and in
nutrition research
because of course we are looking at
whole food matrix and human intervention
studies we need to consider all the bio
actives within that food matrix along
with consumer dnt type of course because
we're all different
so by translating our research sort of
from bedside to bench we can narrow down
a physiological scope of our research
maintaining clinical relevance even at
the level of cell culture studies so we
go from clinical trial to in vitro
experiments of design and then we can
take a targeted neutral genetic approach
and this all supports the potential role
of broccoli diet in cancer interception
so I'm going to leave you with the
question could we cure cancer with
broccoli well I mentioned at the
beginning of the talk and that paper by
Howe at AU in which they look at
sulforaphane in colorectal cancer
interception in mice well could we also
do the same with other sulfur derived
and broccoli metabolites and it's awful
containing broccoli metabolites I should
say could we take the same approach
could the approach be enhanced by
looking at multiple metabolites and the
cumulative synergistic effect of course
diet is a way that everyone in theory
can maintain their own health and and
keep keep metabolic diseases at bay so
could we cure cancer with broccoli
we'll see wait for the escape paper any
questions
Thank You Sophie for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
our first question is there have been
many cell studies using sulforaphane
treatments to model the benefits of a
broccoli diet how relevant are these
studies now we know there are multiple
bio actives which may act
synergistically
right so I think that those sulforaphane
treatments and cell studies are still
extremely relevant as much of what we
understand about the health benefits of
broccoli are are based upon what what we
learned about so for a Fenian cell
studies it's still extremely relevant
however I think it's really important as
research progresses that we consider the
whole food matrix and that means
multiple bioactives
when considering a dietary intervention
because of course the person is
consuming the whole food
now Sophie why did you use si RNA to
create a pebbled knock down with their
crisper alternatives available so this
is quite a good question because CRISPR
has gained a lot of publicity in recent
years about being superior to si RNA in
knockdown experiments but I think it
really depends what question you're
asking and really do you want to spend a
lot of money on an expensive CRISPR
system which might be really great if
you're looking at multiple knockdowns or
doing this in a high-throughput scenario
but I think when taking a knockdown that
hasn't really been studied before of
course you don't know if it's going to
be toxic to your cell and an F RNA is
sufficient just to abrogate expression
and give you an insight before you sort
of take the plunge with with more
committal CRISPR steps
popplet knock down did you achieve with
your si RNA so we managed to get about
40 percent of initial expression so the
gene was knocked down by about 60% in
both the cell lines that we use the SI
RNA in
and Sophie our next question what are
the challenges of designing a long-term
human intervention study with food and
that's another good question because
there are many challenges of course the
first be in compliance and people need
to if if this is a long-term study
adhere to a diet long term and yeah
that's sometimes difficult in the
example of our escape study we were
giving patients one portion of broccoli
soup per week so it really has to be
something that's that's doable if we'd
ask them to consume I don't know a
portion a day we might have really not
had very good compliance and of course
the way you check compliance is usually
through food diaries and people people
tell fibs to be honest people don't want
to tell you that they've had you know
sick portions of chips a week they want
to tell you that they've eaten apples
and all the healthy things so sometimes
the food diaries can be a little bit
misleading and and of course the
controls how do you control for broccoli
without it without it being broccoli so
this is one of the real strengths of our
group in that we have the high glucose
glucosinolate broccoli and standard
broccoli so we have a standard control
which is sometimes difficult with some
food
we are getting some great questions here
Sophie let's look at this one so if you
have you watch the magic pill promises
that eating the correct food can be
superior to drug intervention the phrase
you are what you eat so what is your
opinion on diet as preventing as well as
treating disease well that's a good one
and of course diet keeps your body
healthy and healthy diet means a healthy
body in many circumstances of course
that's not the case for everybody but I
think it really is important to focus on
prevention rather than treatment and in
sort of particularly you know as people
are living longer and there's an
increased burden on on the health
service and the focus tends toward
healthy aging I think diet is is crucial
and not just for sort of the purse
strings of other health service but also
for the psyche of the patient or to be
patient and you want to avoid
medicalizing people where possible and I
think this is where dietary intervention
has a real power
now Sophie what are the challenges of
designing a long-term human intervention
oh excuse me we had already asked that
one just reboot all right well let's
move on to our next one which is our
animal models always relevant as an
intermediate between self studies and
shear with intervention studies now this
is another one that depends very much on
the experimental design and the variable
which you're experimenting we're looking
in that we study broccoli and like I
said in my presentation that's not a
hard sell you're not going to do any
damage with one portion of broccoli soup
a week in a human so we're lucky in that
we can translate our cell studies pretty
much straight into into humans but of
course it depends exactly on what you're
looking at I don't think it's always
relevant as an intermediate but it does
depend what you're looking at and the
nature of your study design
and it looks like we are we are going to
be getting a couple more questions in
our next one is broccoli class as a
superfood and what are the other foods
in this category for cancer
oh well of course our research group has
developed this high glucoraphanin
broccoli which I would consider a
superfood I don't know if superfood is a
more like a marketing term but there are
numerous foods that you can consider
superfood is broccoli perhaps being one
and the others are foods which contain
high levels of anthocyanins for example
and assigning the generally purple
colored compounds which are found in
like aubergine skins to an extent in
tomatoes there's a study in
collaboration with the Quadra Institute
and the John Innes Center here in
Norwich which looks at high anthocyanin
tomatoes for example in cardiovascular
disease risk and so purple foods are
good for you they can be considered
superfoods and broccoli and yeah yeah as
a little bit of a piggyback to that
question what about blackberries Oh
blackberries I'm pretty sure do can turn
out the sign-ins
and but I'm not sure how many how what
volume of anthocyanin they contain like
I say it's generally purple compounds
but purple foods generally contain
varying levels of anthocyanin so yeah
not sure but but I know that I know they
contain on signage but I'm not sure at
what level
alright it looks like we do have another
question right here is to pull for a to
elevate the oxidative stress level in
both of the tested cell line
pardon sigh okay
okay we're fine Ellen right it's all for
a faint elevating the oxidative stress
level in both the tested cell lines yes
so this is how sulforaphane are actually
works in within the cell what it does is
it combines a glutathione which means
the less glutathione available to mop-up
reactive oxygen species so initially it
sort of increases the october oxidative
stress level a little bit which is
enough to tune the antioxidant response
so it does in this is the general action
of sulforaphane within any cells further
understand that it initially acts as a
little bit of a pro-oxidant but its
overall effect within various cell lines
is antioxidant
all right let's see if we have a deal
here
okay what we do have another one our
other greens beneficial for example
spinach kale or arugula
so that's an interesting one because
spinach and kale are sort of in the same
scale certain is in the same family of
vegetable as broccoli and cauliflower
brussel sprouts and Chinese cabbage I
think yeah they're all within the same
sort of brassica family and they all
contain glucosinolates but broccoli
contains the most so that's why we
choose to study broccoli
here's a question for you Sophie what
are your next steps in your research oh
that's an interesting one so the next
steps in my research so I'm looking at
other sulphur metabolites from broccoli
and I have some indication that some may
affect an or us two signaling I might
want to explore that and also I want to
explore how and these sulfur compounds
affect protein structures and whether
they promote this sort of antioxidant
response from other sulfur metabolites
as well as sulforaphane so that's
something I'm quite interested in also
and yeah there's always a million
directions you can take
we do have another question and in
response to our audience that there are
questions that we do not have time for
today
we will be able to so people be able to
answer them via email after this
presentation is over so Sophie our next
question what is the effect of simple
frame on nrf2 oh this is a good one a so
forth aim is the most potent activator
of nrf2 and there is a lot of literature
on that if you google that you'll come
up with so much literature you won't
know what to read first any cell line
any tissue you name it there's been
Studies on sulforaphane and nrf2
you
all right so let's look and see if we
have any more questions let's go ahead
and again like I said to our audience
you may have put in some questions that
we just did not have time for we wait
Sophie will answer questions after after
our presentation provided with the the
contact information that you provided at
the beginning of the presentation so
thank you again Sophie do you have any
final comments for our audience and
final comments feel free to give me an
email or even tweet me if you've got
another question that comes up after
afterwards I'm like a same very prolific
tweeter and happy to respond to any
questions via email
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we do
not have time for today so submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
the registration we would like to thank
laborat and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December of
2018 leverets will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that you know
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye